et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
eric woerth bonjour bonjour ainsi d'être
avec nous députés doivent président de
la commission des finances de
l'assemblée nationale
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale bonjour
creissels bertrand genre et anne bonjour
eric la dépêche christelle on commence
un par un mot sur l'actualité
internationale
eric woerth avec vous puisque après le
détournement d'un avion de ligne
européen par la biélorussie pour arrêter
un opposant au régime de loukachenko
l'union européenne a donc pris des
sanctions dont le renforcement de
sanctions économiques et la fermeture de
l'espace aérien aux appareils biélorusse
emmanuel macron hier il était en
conférence de presse à bruxelles
et il a dit qu'il reconnaissait la
difficulté de l'union européenne à
répondre efficacement la violation du
droit international
nous sommes aujourd'hui à la limite de
la politique de sanctions at il dit est
ce que finalement c'est un demi aveu que
l'union européenne est impuissante sur
ces sujets n'ont pas totalement
impuissante puisque d'abord à l'appel à
des sanctions ce qui est une bonne chose
alors je sais bien qu'il ya déjà des
sanctions sur ce pays qu'en général ça
marche pas très bien les sanctions enfin
il faut bien sanctionner il faut bien le
faire il faut en mesurer les
conséquences
il faut être dissuasif c'est pas
possible que ce type de régime ce régime
autocratique ou fonds auto centrée sur
un dirigeant et qui est là depuis
longtemps et qui veut mener tout
régenter de ses parts à gimeux
démocratique intercepté un avion de
ligne
c'était et vent je sais battait les le
mouvement raciste c'est une démarche de
sauvage est évidemment alors les
différentes compagnies aériennes les
états aussi s'organise
air france par exemple ne survole plus
et de desserts plus non plus ce pays il
faut aller très loin il faut mettre un
coup d'arrêt à ce alors évidemment la
russie soutient cela c'est c'est une
forme de propriété qui sont autour de
ces de ses propres frontières et
l'influencé très très forte
donc il faut aussi agir sur la sur la
russie en respectant par principe
évidemment son identité de pays mais il
faut aussi agir sur la russie pour
essayer de
il faut parler une vente et 2 sont
visibles sur le sol sur le sol heures
open mais inadmissible partout mais
inadmissible sur le sol européen
emmanuel macron avancé une autre idée il
aimerait inviter l'opposition biélorusse
lors du prochain sommet du g7 comprend
c'est vous bon je sais pas comment vont
réagir les autres pays du g7 mais
pourquoi pas je mange pas le jeu
pourquoi pas je pense que il faut
parfois quand même essayer de briser des
lignes ou briser ce qu'il est les les
propos convenus
si on s'énerve autour d'une table d'un
plateau télé pour dire c'est pas bien ça
change rien évidemment autre chose il
faut tenter des des initiatives
nouvelles je ne sais pas si c'est une
bonne initiative je ne pourrais pas le
dire je me spécialise dans les affaires
internationales
j'imagine qu'elle ne laissera pas
totalement à différents jeux près sûr
que ça marche mais mais en tout cas oui
oui je tente on faire des choses
essayant d'aller plus loin mais tendance
des zones d'inconfort ce type de pays
bloquons les comptes
enfin je crois que toutes les
limitations et à l'export et à l'import
bon moment tout ça tout ça fait souffrir
les peuples la plupart du temps est
assez peu les dirigeants mais on voit
d'ailleurs depuis de nombreuses années
sur des pays qui subissent et cela par
contre le blocage
apprendre à prendre l'argent là où il
est dans le portefeuille des dirigeants
ah oui là ça change beaucoup les choses
donc il faut aller très très vite sur le
blocage des avoirs à l'étranger en
europe aux états-unis de ceux de ce type
deux pays la limite de l'acceptabilité
internationale on va parler de
l'actualité au parlement et à
l'assemblée nationale notamment puisque
hier les députés ont voté la réforme de
la justice qui a pour but de renforcer
la confiance entre les français et leur
justice
une grande partie des députés les
républicains se sont abstenus sur ce
texte estimant que le texte ne résout
pas la cassure profonde entre police et
justice est ce qu a dit votre président
de groupe damien abad et eric dupond
moretti à ça il a répondu le vent qui
vous porte est annoncé par la météo
électoraliste vous donner une très très
grande leçon de très très petite
politique qu'est ce que vous répondez
sur une sur réaction
moi ça ne veut rien dire c'est des
propos totalement décalé par rapport à
la réalité c'est vrai que ce texte
s'appelle le s'appelle une le fait de
fans le nom du tech le titre du texte
l'objectif du texte est de réconcilier
grosso modo les français avec
l'institution judiciaire
une cassure profonde allait mesurer
ouais les mesures elle est mesurée par
les enquêtes d'opinion on y croit on n'y
croit pas mais enfin je pense que c'est
la vérité alors beaucoup de magistrats
de très très grande qualité la question
elle est pas personne par personne
berne a évidemment besoin d'une justice
forte indépendante ça va de soi allez en
elle dans la dépendance veut dire la
responsabilité des erreurs et d'assumer
les heures d'éviter lente reçoit
judiciaire comme dans d'autres
professions il est très très élevé et de
dire qu'on va réconcilier les français
avec la justice au travers d'un texte
comme celui-là c'est évidemment pas vrai
enfin il ya un décalage énorme entre
l'ambition qui est affiché et puis la
réalité du taxi a plein de bonnes choses
d'ailleurs les républicains ont voté
pour la plupart des articles à
l'assemblée nationale du texte
le problème ça résout pas du tout le
problème ça améliore les choses c'est un
texte commun en a eu beaucoup qui sont
des textes qu'ils font
des améliorations au fur et à mesure de
tel ou tel point qu'ils peuvent être
encore une fois très utile mais c'est
pas un texte ambitieux pas du tout et je
gardais soul c'est très bien mais ceux
qui ont beaucoup critiqué la justice ces
derniers temps il ya les policiers ce
que vous étiez la manifestation devant
l'assemblée jr
j'ai testé c'était je crois notre notre
devoir d'y d'y être pour montrer à quel
point lorsqu'on attaque les
représentants de l'autorité dans un pays
aussi démocratique que le nôtre hip hop
ça ne peut pas rester sans réponse tout
ça ne peut pas être de fausses ou de
mauvaise réponse donc j étais comme la
le plupart d'ailleurs des groupes
politiques sauf les insoumis d'ailleurs
je ne sais pas il aime pas la police et
c'est leur problème c'est qu'ils
n'aiment pas fâché pas si on peut dire
qu'on aime ou qu'on aime pas la police
et la police est une nécessité absolue
dans un état démocratique pilotés par
des institutions républicaines
enfin quand je dis ça j'ai l'impression
de faire de la prose quoi c'était
évident à c'est la nature des choses
mais mais les jets de mélenchon n'aime
pas la police je ne sais pas ce que lui
a faite mais elle a besoin dans un état
républicain évidemment d'une policand
jeudi police gendarmerie les forces de
l'ordre extrêmement forte et on a besoin
évidemment dans ce cas là d'un
gouvernement qui respecte la police et
d'une chaîne judiciaire qui derrière
applique la loi de la façon la plus
ferme possible pour éviter les les
réitération de delhi est ce qui manque
dans le texte justice c'est quelque
chose de ça par exemple les peines
plancher par exemple des peines très
forte xavier bertrand a proposé mais ça
pourrait être d'autre chose très fort
pour tous ceux qui sont attaqués dans
leur fonction d'autorité oui mais à
force de dire que rien et efficace jeu
juste fait remarquer que la délinquance
augmente donc si c'est le jeu on peut
toujours dire quand ya pas de
proposition en face donc je pense que
c'est prêt je ne sais pas la proposition
elle est multifactoriel elle est bien
plus importante que ça ça va de l'école
à la partouze avec mais la réalité à un
moment donné c'est la dissuasion cela
peines dissuasives comme il ya une
dissuasion nucléaire il doit y avoir une
dissuasion judiciaire dans ces
manifestations il y avait aussi gérald
darmanin ministre de l'intérieur est ce
que c'est la place d'un ministre
l assister à une manifestation devant un
effort de la santé has qui a été un peu
surpris par cette décision qui prend
évidemment un contre-pied vu que c'était
quand même une manifestation alors
n'était pas anti gouvernementales
vraiment elle était au contraire et
crier leur colère de voir leurs
collègues nationale c'est pas le
gouvernement
oui mais fort heureusement qu'on a le
droit contrairement à ce que croient
madame pulvar heureusement qu'on a le
droit de manifester devant l'assemblée
nationale sans revenir aux ligues du
passé c'est la place d'un ministre
ministre l'intérieur
non je ne pense pas d'ailleurs tout le
monde était mal à l'aise avec
avec ça je pense que le miz l'intérieur
essayer de montrer à chaque fois que
leur lui la police en ont peur on les
ministres en général aiment bien les
personnes dont elles n'ont sur laquelle
ils ont une autorité mais c'est pas sa
place non je ne crois pas je pense
d'ailleurs qu'il est resté très peu moi
j'ai juste pu le croiser quand ils
repartaient ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens
ce qui compte c'est ce qu'il fait c'est
pas là mais c'est une forme d'aveu
d'impuissance
ce qui est assez vrai donc c'est ce
qu'il fait a misé l'intérieur ça court
pas après tout les tous les délits où
tous les crimes en france en se
propulsant sur les terrains mais ni ni
dans une manifestation
ça ça agi en liaison avec son collègue
de la deux
this on voit bien que plus que jamais le
lien police justice qui est une vieille
histoire ça fait très longtemps qu'on en
parle parce que s'il ya un lien il est
naturel il ya un moment donné quand il
ya une rupture il faut la regarder de
très très près et là il ya une rupture
aujourd'hui entre police et justice je
pense qu'il ya une vraie rupture c'est à
dire qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
arrêtés auraient arrêté par la police
qui prend des risques en le faisant je
pense notamment en tout toute l'économie
souterraine et pacy souterraine que ça
dans beaucoup de quartiers delà de la
drogue qui verront la société entière
faut évidemment augmenter le niveau
dissuasion et quand on touche une
personne qui est investi de l'autorité
républicaine
il faut que la sanction soit exemplaire
quand je qu'entends je
pas que la police quand je vois ce maire
qui se fait fracasser la tête les jambes
enfin on a ici le tuer quand on en
arrive à cela pour des dépôts sauvages
j'ai été maire gg numéros aussi agi
contre plein d'incivilités de et de
directement physiquement et tous les
maires le le fond enfin il ya un moment
donné il faut que la sanction elle soit
tout à fait exemplaire que sont pas
seulement contre les agresseurs de
forces de l'ordre mais contre oui mais
les élus séparent ils sont porteurs
d'une autorité amer dans sa commune il
est officier de police judiciaire
donc évidemment il faut que ce soit la
dissuasion elle est fondamentale elle
fonctionne dans le domaine militaire
dans le domaine du rapport de force
elle est fondamentale donc on ne peut
pas avoir que des micros pen qui
s'enchaînent les unes après les autres
des manque de suivi de ce type de de
grande délinquance
on va passer à la crise sanitaire eric
woerth puisque un autre texte qui a été
votée hier par les députés c'est celui
sur l'état d'urgence sanitaire après un
accord entre députés et sénateurs il
instaure notamment le pass sanitaires
les députés de gauche ils ont annoncé
qu'ils allaient saisir le conseil
constitutionnel ils vont jusqu'à parler
d' autoritarisme ce que vous comprenez
cette démarche vous savez je le relis et
c'est la première partie de nos
discussions c'est que quand beaucoup de
partis politiques parce que beaucoup
notamment sur la gauche appellent à une
forme de laxisme de laisser aller
général où on met sur le même plan la
victime et est celui qui a le délinquant
à ce moment là on perd à peu près pied
les signaux qu'on envoie la société
c'est faites ce que vous voulez de toute
façon vous ne paierez jamais pour ce que
vous avez vous avez fait je joue je
confesse je regrette ce type de 2,2 de
signal et dans le pass sanitaire c'est
pareil il ya un moment donné il faut
bien qu'ils dépassent sanitaires il faut
mieux et qui est des moments où on
exerce de l'autorité si vous acceptez
d'être vacciné vous êtes vacciné et puis
très bien vous avez un pass sanitaire
vous à pouvait aller les rassemblements
de 1000 personnes à partir d'une du neuf
du 9 juin
ou si vous avez un test négatif il faut
bien à un moment donné quand on veut
respecter les autres respecter soi-même
un certain nombre de règles
et puis après il ya la liberté la
liberté de ne pas se faire vacciner elle
est pleine et entière en france eh bien
elle celui qui décide d'utiliser cette
liberté et doit aussi en accepter les
les conséquences et dire qu'il ne peut
pas mettre la vie des autres en danger
évidemment qu'il faut un pass sanitaire
est ce que c'est le bon moment alors
même que tous les français ne peuvent
pas encore aujourd'hui se faire vacciner
est ce qu'il ya une inégalité des sites
où les français peuvent se veut un jeu
le gouvernement a ouvert totalement la
difficile
le grand jeu grosso modo moi j'ai
compris que tout le monde pouvait se
faire vacciner aujourd'hui à tellement
de liste de priorités j'ai compris qu'à
la fin du mois
de toute façon tout le monde pouvait se
faire vacciner donc le gouvernement à
accélérer et dieu sait qu'on lui avait
demandé de le de le faire donc il ya un
accès aux vaccins aujourd'hui à peu près
à peu près correct donc évidemment dans
la première partie
quand il y avait trois vaccins par
semaine c'était quand même un tout petit
peu plus difficile mais à partir du
moment où on est dans une chaîne
vaccinale qui fonctionne maintenant bien
comme dans tous les autres pays
il faut absolument pouvoir avoir un
basset leader maintenant si vous n'êtes
pas vacciné vous avez toujours la
possibilité d'avoir un test pcr
vous allez d'autres poucho possibilité
que la vaccination pour vous permettre
d'accéder d'user de votre liberté
on va parler de la crise économique eric
woerth et des suites du quoi qu'il en
coûte est ce que pour vous les exécutifs
à raison de miser sur un rebond de la
croissance à venir
ab il y aura évidemment redon enfin
quand vous êtes au fond de la piscine
elle est à un moment donné le ce fameux
coup de coup de talon il arrive quoi
donc évidemment qu'il y aura un rebond
la vraie question c'est à quel moment on
commence à rattraper l'endroit où doudou
on est parti c'est à dire de la vente
coville et de lavande qu'ovide avec la
croissance qui aurait dû se faire
et puis comment on arrive pas uniquement
à rattraper mais comme on arrive à
transformer à à changer à faire bouger
notre notre notre notre économie c'est à
dire en quoi la crise peut être un
accélérateur de deux réformes de
transformation mais qu'importe les mots
et mais ce qui importe c'est de le faire
comment ce tout ce temps perdu à lutter
contre la crise tant perdu économique
temps perdu humain social et c'est toute
cette souffrance au fond qu'est compte
accumulé les pays et la france aussi
comment on peut en faire une chance pour
le pour notre pays et donc accélérer les
mutations sociales économiques numérique
écologique de notre de notre pays c'est
l'enjeu et au delà de la relance il ya
évidemment une phase de transition
moi je le dis déjà depuis plusieurs mois
il eut la phase d'urgence il ya
obligatoirement une phase de transition
entre l'urgence et la relance à dire que
évidemment il ya plein de profession qui
souffre encore de tout cela il ya des
morts il ya des professions qui sont en
pleine mutation donc ils prendront du
temps pour rebondir et celle là il faut
continuer à les aider pour vous un
second plan de relance s'imposerait on
sait qu'il en est question aujourd'hui
déjà on pourrait imposer le premier
qu'il faut déjà que le premier qui a été
votée il ya quelques mois soit en partie
consommé c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs c'est assez normal que ce
soit pas le cas à peu près 30% du du
prend le plan de relance est aujourd'hui
engagée c'est déjà pas mal
allons-nous année
de second plan de relance avant d'avoir
entièrement consommé le premier pourra
pas entièrement mais enfin en tout cas
faut se poser des questions dit si d'ici
la rentrée sans doute pourquoi parce que
lorsqu'il faut évaluer les mesures il ya
plein de mesures s'essayer à peu un peu
dans tous les sens sur la relance sur le
social sur l'économique sur l'écho logik
sur le numérique on voit bien que
beaucoup d'entreprises sont d'ailleurs
très très très soucieuse de bien savoir
ce qu'elle vous pouvoir faire beaucoup
dead notamment d' aide à
l'investissement et ça c'est une bonne
chose mais votez pour eux les nounous
nous mêmes avons proposé un plan de
relance de la même de la même nature
donc maintenant il faut savoir comment
il va être exécutée et surtout quel
impact il assure sur le potentiel de
croissance de notre pays l'idée c'est
que d'autres pays ils aillent plus vite
après la crise qu'il a un potentiel de
croissance plus importants sinon ça ne
marchera pas ça vous paraît en prendre
le chemin
bah ouais je pense que je pense qu'on va
accélérer l'investissement dans les
entreprises
je vois pas mal d'entreprises qui ont
accès à des aides financières sur leurs
investissements de productif donc ça va
augmenter la robotisation par exemple de
la balade de l'entreprise france qu'on a
absolument besoin en est également la
numérisation on en a absolument besoin
le verdissement ça va de soi et puis ça
crée des emplois donc on a absolument
besoin de faire le point sur l'état du
plan de relance d'aujourd'hui pour
reconduire éventuellement certaines
mesures très ciblées sur
l'investissement mais tout ça ça a un
prix et ce à un prix gigantesque mais ya
pas que ça quand le ministre de
l'éducation nationale annonce une
nouvelle augmentation des des
professeurs des enseignants il a raison
les enseignants sont pas très bien payé
et curieusement aux deux bouts de la vie
on paye mal les gens on paye mal les
gens pour éduquer vos enfants c'est
sûrement le
le lait les éleveurs des enfants c'est
ce qu'on a de plus cher dans toutes les
familles dont combes et on paye mal ce
qui en selle et puis de l'autre côté de
la vie quand c'est nos parents ont un
âge où ils ont besoin d'une aide on paye
très mal les gens qui les aident les
aides-soignantes les aides à domicile
etc
les paye très minces donc on voit bien
que une société qui doit prendre
conscience de cela
maintenant il faut aussi le faire avec
région si on augmente les enseignants
j'ai pas d'opposition majeure à
augmenter les enseignants mais c'est là
que tous les ans on voit évidemment
devoir payer cette augmentation du fonds
derrière qui ait des contreparties avec
les enseignants pas des punitions mais
des contreparties dans la manière de
travailler sa vis-à-vis des enseignants
eux-mêmes vis-à-vis des personnes
concernées il faut que c'était la
contrepartie contrepartie ça peut être
le temps de travail ça peut être la
qualité du travail ça peut être la
rémunération à un moment donné au mérite
ça peut être beaucoup de choses comme ça
qui sont très augmentée j'entends des
enseignants pour vous m'aimez par
exemple pourquoi pas pourquoi pas et il
faut en discuter avec les enseignants
il faut une discussion et puis pas une
discussion idéologie ferme est arrivé
comme on en a l'habitude où on ferme
absolument tout en france et qu'on ne
peut plus rien se dire
donc oui à l'augmentation mais des
contreparties claires et précises et ça
c'était absolument absolument nécessaire
puis d'autre part faut maîtriser les
autres dépenses le gouvernement ne parle
que d'eux que de que d'augmentation des
dépenses d'investissement mais pâques
d'investissement quand le gouvernement
dit les jeunes devront avoir une
allocation supplémentaire 500 euros avec
là aussi des contreparties demandées aux
jo ça ressemble à ce qu'on appelle la
garantie jeunes qui est un dispositif
qui existe depuis longtemps gelé
proposer dès le mois de novembre mais
j'ai indiqué j'ai indiqué au
gouvernement parce que les jeunes en ont
besoin que ils ont une phase de
transition très très considérable compte
tenu de cette année et demi ou deux ans
et pour un jeune c'est considérable
comme temps ils ont besoin d'être d'être
aidés mais un c'est pas le rsa douce et
ponctuel 3 y ait une contrepartie
et puis 4 si on le fait ça veut dire
qu'il ya d'autres choses qu'on ne doit
pas faire il faut que le gouvernement
montre sa capacité également à maîtriser
la dépense publique
sinon le mur de la dette à un moment
donné s'écrouler sur nous
on va parler des régionales temps
terminé cristallerie un peu de politique
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
les l air ce sont un petit peu
réconcilié depuis le psychodrame qui
s'est déroulé en paca récemment le
psychodrame c'est aussi un symptôme
si le symptôme de l'absence de candidat
pour l'instant l'élection présidentielle
donc de quelqu'un en capacité de faire
une synthèse sur ce qui est proposé
tous jouent toutes les paroles des uns
et des autres sont aujourd'hui sur le
même plan quelqu'un dans une autre
matinée elle va dire le contraire de ce
que j'ai dit sera mis sur le même plan
que moi est celui qui sera au milieu
sera mis également sur le même plan le
problème du du du chef
aujourd'hui les chefs sont ceux qui se
présentent en l'élection présidentielle
c'est de faire des synthèses et puis
après par rapport aux 7,5 de l'absence
de candidat ou c'est aussi le symptôme
de l'absence d'un vrai chef à la tête
des républicains n'ont mené par
christian jacob et président des
républicains et fait bien son job de
président des républicains
bien sûr elle est question d n'est pas
là dans moins d'un an des élections
présidentielles donc évidemment ce qui
est très important c'est d'avoir un
candidat qui puisse être sélectionné
pour le 2ème tour parce que si c'est
pour faire de la figuration
c'est pas important mais ce qui est
important c'est aussi qu'ils
représentent des idées je suis plus
attentifs aujourd'hui aux idées coco job
part évidemment faux dilemme pour les
porter c'est je suis bien d'accord
notamment lorsque les idées sont les
visées mission de réformer notre pays
faut déjà avoir des idées claires sur ce
que l'on veut faire et sur ce que l'on
ne veut pas faire etc
les républicains aujourd'hui travaille
beaucoup dans des conventions l'accord
une fière mais on a besoin aujourd'hui
de porter des ambitions très forte pour
notre pays et porter ses ambitions c'est
aussi avoir un candidat à l'élection
présidentielle en tout cas un candidat
qui porte les idées d'une droite
régaliennes européenne barabeau gris
souveraine mais pas souverainiste j'ai
d'ailleurs qui ne pense pas que toutes
les fermetures des frontières
vale vale qui ne pense pas que la peur
doit être ceux qui le meilleur des
sentiments qu'ils puissent générer
l'éducation des nations on a on a besoin
de gens ouverts non naïf bon il ya plein
de gens qui dans l'est républicain
représente la pas tout le monde mais
beaucoup comme qui un plein plein de
monde c'était l'idée aussi bertrand
représente représente que je pense la
xavier il n'a pas du tout dit quel était
son propre programme est d'ailleurs
heureusement qu'il ne le dit pas
maintenant l'élection présidentielle a
dit beaucoup de gens et oui il a dit des
choses mais des choses beaucoup trop
vague pour une élection présidentielle
et c'est pas le moment
ça viendra j'imagine à partir de
l'automne mais c'est vrai pour valérie
pécresse
c'est vrai pour beaucoup d'autres c'est
vrai pour michel barnier il ya beaucoup
de candidats possibles dans nos rangs il
faudrait un moment donné passer du trop
plein c'est c'est d'abord de mettre le
au clair nos idées j'ai moi j'y tiens
beaucoup donc moi je mens je soutiendrai
quelqu'un qui est qui qui a envie d'une
dune vainqueur vie d'un pays qui vivent
dans l'autorité républicaine qui ne
s'excuse pas de l'autorité républicaine
qui ne confond pas l'autorité et
l'autoritarisme qui ne confond pas avec
des coups de menton à tout moment et qui
croit à l'ouverture en versant dans un
autre de notre pays on verra bien mais
on verra en fonction des projets on
verra ce que défendre c'est une élection
profondément personnelle il ya un moment
donné il ya un moment donné la personne
n est pas parce qu on est ami avec elle
ou qu'on a envie de partir avec elle
c'est pas l'élection cantonale
excusez moi c'est qu'il ya un moment
donné dans cette personne ni à la
représentation de notre pays de notre
juste de notre pays y porte
et ouais elle porte une partie de
nous-mêmes donc moi j'attends que cette
personne elles disent à un moment donné
ce qu'elle a envie de faire je juge
jusqu'où elle a envie d'entraîner les
français l'envi de la france où les
sondages ça compte pas quand vous voyez
ce week-end le sondage ifop xavier
bertrand fait quasiment le double des
autres concurrents à droite pour vous
six 6 bien sûr que ça compte et ça
compte énormément
mais on verra en fonction de l'évolution
des sondages on verra surtout à la fin
des élections régionales commencera
aussi tu le mot
2 le monde politique et puis d'autres
peuvent surgir on en dit jamais donc on
verra bien tout cela
ce qui compte c'est que il y ait à un
moment donné un corpus de droite
républicaine qui soit clairement
représenter à l'élection présidentielle
avec évidemment une chance de une chance
fondamental de gagner il faut évidemment
rassemblé beaucoup rassembler rien ne se
fera sur l'opposition des uns avec les
autres et ce sera le mot de la fin merci
eric woerth merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nos christelle la une de la dépêche
et oui le passé ni termes d'emploi c'est
vrai que c'est un nouveau une nouvelle
complexité dans cette crise sanitaire et
c'est à lire aujourd'hui dans la dépêche
merci christelle merci rigaux
[Musique]